projections from the Democratic Super
Tuesday primaries in the US show former
Vice President Joe Biden taking the lead
against his rivals Biden has clinched
victories in eight states so far with an
especially strong showing in the south
exit polls linked his success to strong
support from african-american older and
suburban voters meanwhile senator Bernie
Sanders has won three states and is on
track to win the biggest prize
California Sanders is particularly
popular with younger and Latino voters
earlier Bernie Sanders addressed a
raucous crowd of supporters in his home
state of Vermont despite losing ground
to Biden he was upbeat about his chances
of becoming the Democratic Party's
presidential candidate tonight I tell
you with absolute confidence we are
gonna win the Democratic nomination
and we are going to defeat the most
dangerous precedent in the history of
this country
we're gonna win
well DW a reporter William glueck Roth
is with me here in the studio and DW
correspondent and a phenomena is in Los
Angeles welcome to you both let's start
with you William decisive day for the
Democrats of course in choosing who they
want to challenge Donald Trump what do
things stand now
well definitely some big takeaways one
money doesn't necessarily buy you
elections Michael Bloomberg put 500
million dollars into me being big on
Super Tuesday states and now he might be
reassessing his campaign it helps to
lose your competition Biden lost his
moderate competitors after the South
Carolina vote and a lot of those votes
have now gone to him which has propelled
him into the lead now at least as things
currently stand in terms of Delegates
and this is about delegates not about
States remember this is a proportional
vote so the popular vote gets translated
into delegates which means it's not just
who wins a state but even someone
showing a strong second place finish in
various states might do very well in
racking up those numbers it's really the
spread between first and second and even
in some cases second and third so this
is very much about numbers it's very
much a math game now not only that magic
word momentum that everybody likes to
talk about okay big states California
and Texas those are the ones to watch on
this Super Tuesday
ilex around different nominees out in
California for us of excited California
has the most delegates up for grabs in
Super Tuesday Bernie Sanders was slated
to take it how's it looking for them and
the other candidates say well it looks
good for Bernie Sanders here according
to Associated Press projections he won
this state there are other news sources
such as the u.s. TV networks who are
more hesitant just saying that Sanders
is leading here in California and we
also have to add that the majority of
the precincts they have to report their
results yet but of course it is the
biggest price on Super Tuesday and it is
crucial for senator Sanders to win here
because the state
place to his strengths with young
liberals with Latino voters with young
voters and all of them support his
vision for America's future but we also
have to say that to our candidates Mike
Bloomberg and Joe Biden seems to have
cleared that 15% threshold of all those
and it could be that they can claim a
significant number of Delegates here in
California
okay so Bernie Sanders looking good in
California but of course it's going to
take a while before we get the final
results from from Super Tuesday and we
have to keep in mind that Joe Biden is
still the man to beat it looks like he's
got the most out of gets at this point
let's hear what he had to say speaking
to his supporters earlier
[Applause]
and we're told well when you got to
Super Tuesday be over well it may be
over for the other guy Joe Biden
sounding confident Alexandre just days
ahead of the Super Tuesday primary
moderate Democrats threw their weight
behind Joe Biden has it given him a
boost of course that's the case he is
having a great night tonight we have to
say just remember how he was struggling
a week ago when his critics said that he
is not the right candidate for the party
to rally around after very disappointing
performance and in the Iowa and in New
Hampshire but then we saw his sweeping
victory in South Carolina and great
support of african-americans for Joe
Biden and then the endorsements from the
party establishment started to coming in
with this surprising move by Amy
Klobuchar and Peter Budaj each two of
his rivals who dropped out of the race
and endorsed Joe Biden so he is
definitely having momentum right now
William we have two clear frontrunners
right now in Joe Biden and Bernie
Sanders Elizabeth Warren and Michael
Bloomberg as you already mentioned have
fallen quite far behind can we expect
them to drop out in the next days weeks
and if so what kind of impacts are gonna
have only one doesn't have to wonder
what this was all about with Michael
Bloomberg his strategy with Super
Tuesday putting all this money in an
incredible amount of money half a
billion dollars just for him to maybe
reassess his campaign tomorrow which of
course is who code for dropping out
Elizabeth Warren is the bigger question
mark she doesn't have the numbers she
doesn't have the popularity but as
Alexandra mentioned there's this magic
15% threshold that if you get over 15%
of the vote in various states and parts
of states you're still able to get
delegates which could be just enough to
make her just competitive enough to push
all the way through remember there's
still a lot more states left a lot more
delegates out
to get to that national convention in
the summer and fight for the nomination
against Bernie Sanders and Joe Biden and
that might be Elizabeth Warren's
strategy now but she may do what
Klobuchar and Buddha judge did in the
centrist column doing it on the the the
progressive side dropping out and
putting her support behind Bernie
Sanders we'll just have to see if that's
the tax she takes still some suspense
left in the Democratic nomination race
William good craft tier in Berlin and
out in Los Angeles
Alexander for now and thank you both
very much